jesse is whether some Boise Idaho hi
Jesse how are you yeah Dave how you
doing better than I deserve what's up
hey so my girlfriend and I shouldn't see
my my girlfriend's mother she's getting
an inheritance from her mother passing
away and she's gonna give us 215,000 and
I guess my thing is we've got about
10,000 in credit card debt about 50,000
and student loans and right now we're
living in an apartment and I'm just not
exactly sure what to do with the money
and then how to avoid getting super
taxed on it have any taxes on it at all
okay then taxable income a gift is not
taxable and this is a gift it's her
money she's giving it to you there's no
taxes on it to you now she needs to go
see an estate planning attorney this is
your mom giving you 215,000 right
my girlfriend's on her girlfriend your
girlfriend's mom holy crap why would she
give you money she would give money
where we're pretty much married that's
now you're not pretty much there's no
such thing as pretty much married you're
either married or you're not okay I mean
legally this woman is a nutburger if she
gives you money right you're not married
because you could just leave indeed
that's just silly so I mean that that's
just nutty so I wouldn't do that but if
she gives her daughter money let's go
back to that for a second okay and try
to answer your question but dude you
really can't treat this as a legal
couple because it leaves this lady
that's being $215,000 for the generous
tremendously exposed and you just don't
want it's not fair to her so anyway she
needs to see an attorney and is her
estate over five million dollars
currently no okay then she can give you
this money without any gift tax if she
claims it write this down under the
unified
a state tax credit she's using up part
of her federal estate tax exemption upon
her death by giving it to you now if she
just writes you a check she's going to
end up with a hundred thousand dollars
in taxes do not do that she needs to see
an attorney into the unified estate tax
credit now once she gives that to her
daughter her daughter should become debt
free and if her daughter wants to buy a
house and her daughter's name that's
fine and if her daughter is living with
a guy that would be named Jesse then
he's living in someone else's house
that's the legal way to put this
together okay yeah and that way you're
not leaving these ladies legally exposed
to a mess however if Jesse were to get
married prior to this happening then
Jesse and his wife would be living in a
debt-free house the student loans would
be paid off credit cards would be paid
off and caught up we'd be debt-free with
an emergency fund pay cash for a hundred
and twenty thousand dollar house in
Boise Idaho and that's probably your
best game scenario this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh